Okay.
This is a very interesting story and there's
a couple of different elements to it, which
I want to talk about it.
It kind of set the stage.
Many of you know that there's currently a
crisis in Venezuela and it involves the despotic
authoritarian autocrat, Nicolas Maduro.
And as a principled progressive, I want the
United States to stay absolutely out of Venezuela.
And I also want Nicolas Maduro to go who has
ravaged the country.
And I want an actual democratic leader, not
a puppet of the United States to come to power
and to start working on the difficult problems
that Venezuela has to solve for itself.
That's my view because I'm a progressive.
But in the middle of all of this, there are
lots of politics to be sorted out and one
of those elements relates to American companies
doing business with the Maduro regime.
It relates to hypocrisy is of individual American
elected officials.
There are all sorts of other political issues
that are, that are in the mix here.
The geopolitical implications of Russia's
perspective on what's going on in Venezuela,
the Cuban component than the possible legality
or illegality of Cuban involvement in Venezuela
for a long time, which is another issue that
there's some really smart pieces out there
that I recommend you read, but in a totally
sort of stunning but also not altogether surprising
revelation given that Trump is involved with
all sorts of dirty players.
The Miami Herald is now reporting that Donald
Trump's company sold a luxury property in
the Dominican Republic to a shell company,
apparently tied to the Nicolas Maduro regime
of Venezuela and specifically who we're talking
about is the second most powerful person in
the Maduro government.
His name is doc Dato Cabelo Cabelo, or as
we would say in Argentina, Gabby's Asia who
is under US sanctions personally for allegedly
trafficking drugs and laundering money.
Now I will make it abundantly clear, it's
not believed that this transaction would rise
to the level of criminality because it allegedly
took place in 2015 when a, this individual
was not yet under sanctions, but I don't even
actually care so much about the brazen double
standards.
Uh, you know, understand that Trump considers
meddling in Venezuela against the Maduro regime
as president.
And just years ago he was selling property
to people associated with the Maduro regime.
We're accustomed to the double standards.
There is countless, there's boundless hypocrisy.
It's sort of pedestrian and boring at this
point.
And we know that Republicans and Trumpists
don't care about the hypocrisy and double
standards of Donald Trump.
So it's like barely even worth discussing.
The story here is that this is not rare.
What I mean by that is Donald Trump is involved
in all sorts of sketchy financial transactions,
presumed money laundering of all kinds for
uh, many for individuals, uh, in countries
that are under sanction at this point in time.
So remember the Trump organization participated
in what they appear to have known was a money
laundering operation involving a branch of
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard that worked
on getting components for weapons of mass
destruction.
So again, Trump, Iran is terrible even though
they didn't actually violate any of the provisions
of the Iran deal that they signed with President
Obama were out of the Iran deal screw Iran.
But Trump's organization reportedly involved
in a money laundering scheme for the people
who are obtaining or working to obtain and
develop weapons of mass destruction in Iran.
Total blatant hypocrisy.
Also, not rare.
Trump has done this before.
There's an article in the New Yorker from
two years ago called Donald Trump's worst
deal, which outlines a lot of the comings
and goings of that Iranian national guard.
A Revolutionary Guard fiasco are endless projects
were Trump and his kids have misled buyers
about real estate deals.
Look for example at the Propublica article
from 2018 called here are the Trump projects
were Ivanka and her dad misled buyers.
This is a scamster criminal who is in the
White House, so of course there are dozens
of stories like this and it's not surprising
that it involves a Russian oligarchs tied
to Putin.
As I told you earlier in the program, it involves
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard and now it
reportedly involves Nicolas Maduro is number
two, uh, number two guy.
We could go even further.
I could talk to you in detail and I think
maybe we have discussed this on the program
about the fiasco in Baku Azerbaijan, which
we could do an entire show about what went
on with Trump's dealings there.
Trump has likely been a criminal as long as
he's been a player in New York and world real
estate.
And if there's anything good that comes from
the Donald Trump presidency because it's basically
all bad, it would be that maybe it will expose
the level of criminality that Donald Trump's
business has been involved in.
And if we're lucky, it doesn't seem like this
is definitely going to be the case.
But if we're lucky, maybe all of these investigations
and revelations that come from the spotlight
being on Donald Trump is president of the
United States.
Maybe it will let us pierce the kleptocracy,
uh, of, of that, that Donald Trump and the
people around him have perpetuated.
And maybe somebody will be held accountable
at some point for some small piece of these
misdeeds that again, are not rare in the sense
that it's not just Trump that does this stuff.
Most of the people that do the shady business
that Trump has been doing for decades are
sort of smart enough, quite frankly, to realize
that running for elected office, running for
anything where there would be an expectation
that you would, uh, disclose your, your full
finances, where there would be a spotlight
and a micro, uh, a, a magnifying glass placed
on what you've been doing in business and
professionally, most super rich dudes like
Trump recognize they shouldn't go anywhere
near politics because this is exactly the
type of thing that could happen.
We've got an opportunity now with Donald Trump
to actually hold one of these, uh, sort of
gilded families accountable for stuff that
tons of rich dudes, uh, and guys and Gals,
uh, are, are doing and have been doing and
almost always are not held accountable for.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
While you're there, follow me.
I'm on Instagram at David's
dot Hackmann we'll take a quick break and
we have so much more still upcoming on today's
show